good morning john i recently uh you know
noticed as you do
that my glasses were disgustingly filthy
usually when i noticed this i will uh
just go about my day and that's what i
did
and then later i realized that they were
still super filthy and then
a day after that i was like okay i'm
gonna clean my glasses but then
i had a thought what exactly is
on them what is all that stuff
and i also realized that i have a
microscope and so i continued
to not wash my glasses for seven full
days and so now it is time
for me to show you what is it
just what is it because i can do that
because i have a microscope let's go
warning from hank from the future what
you are about to see
is not great oh green
why is it green the mucus
okay well there's a big something what's
that
why is it a color those are all just
like individual little
dots of grease that down there is a skin
cell
oh wow oh god
is that a hair that must be a hair with
just some
just some sebaceous stuff on it you can
see the scratches on my lens too that's
interesting
mostly i'd guess that these are skin
cells or just like flakes of skin
i think it's what's happening and then
hairs that's a big scratch
so one thing that i i'm gonna try now
with one side is to actually put a slide
cover on and you know it's about it's
roughly the same as what we were looking
at oh gosh
this just flakes the skin lots of flakes
of skin
oh that's definitely a fiber jeez
what is happening how is that even stuck
i mean i guess it's tiny it's this tiny
little thread
that came off of some of my clothes or a
bed sheet or something
oh that's a big old hair whoa it's huge
oh my god how is that on my glasses
we need some anti-stick technology on
glasses you guys
i'm so sorry to everyone in my family
for never cleaning my glasses
and i'm so sorry to all of you for like
subjecting you to my
facebookers and you know a similar story
on this
on this lens skin cells aplenty
just flakes of skin occasional threads
and hairs
and lots and lots and lots of globs of
oil here's another hair for a thread for
you
what those are salt crystals i think i'm
just
guessing but they look too rectangular
to be organic
a drop of sweat that dried up maybe
that's kind of cool i hate it
it's like the freaking surface of
mercury up in here
the thing i didn't expect was all of the
globs of
oil admittedly i haven't washed these
glasses
in a week does it just leap off of my
face
oh my god we are factories we make so
much stuff with our bodies
and it is upsetting oh i have to go i
have to go shoot scishow
no terrible and i have to clean my
glasses in order to do it do you think
that's an eyelash
it's tiny it's probably an eyelash
oh god i'm gonna get some soap and water
and i'm gonna clean these boys out right
now
oh lord well john oh
there's still a slide cover on that one
wow glad it didn't go in my eye
remember to clean your glasses and
that's really the whole moral of this
story i'm so glad that we got to learn
these things together
today i'll see you on tuesday
whoa okay that's why there's a sandbag
on there